[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد ذكرت صحيفه
هارتس اسرائيليه ان شركه اسرائيليه مقرها
قبرص ارسل التقنيه مراقبه متطوره لقوه
الدعم السريع بالصدام بقياده محمد حمدان
دلو حميدتي وافاد تقرير صحيفه ان القوات
الدعم السريع بالسودان نقلت شحنه الاجهزه
الاسرائيليه الى منطقه الدار فور قبل ان
ياخذ الجيش السوداني معلوماتنا بشانها
واوضحت صحيفه الاسرائيليه كذلك ان القوات
الدعم السريع بالسودان لديها علاقات
بشركات اسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
مناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من يكسر رؤى
عربيه
بمركز دراسات الدوليه اهلا بك ومن الخرطوم
المحلل السياسي احمد يحيى اهلا بكم من
ضيوف الكرام الى هذا النقاش واسمحوا لي ان
ابدا مع رؤى السيد رؤى اهلا بك معنا لماذا
الدعم السريع يتولى الدخول في مثل هكذا
اا اتصالات اولا مع الخارج تمثيل السودان
ثانيا واقتناء مثل هكذا اجهزه مراقبه
عاليه الدقه
اول حاجه مساء الخير لكل المشاهدين
والمسلمين الكرام الحقيقه دي ما اول مره
يتصدر فيها الدعم السريع او حميدي عناوين
الصحف في تقارير مثل هذه حميدتي يتنقل
نقله نوعيه عبره سنين خصوص نقله النوعيه
من 2018 حتى الان وتقنين وجود قوات الدعم
السريع هو موازيه للجيش نشكر في 2019 صدر
مقال من جلوك كان بيتكلم عن تورط حميتي
ودفع سته مليون دولار للشركه الكنديه لكي
يتم تبيض صورته اعلاميا همم كذلك هذه
الشركه الكنديه الوقت ده كان مسؤول عنها
برده همم احد اعضاء الاستخبارات السابقه
في الحكومه الاسرائيليه همم من هنا بيقول
انه حتى عنده صلاه كبيره في الخارج في
الداخل صلاته في الخارج ايضا هو تصدر
الملفات اللي هي عندها علاقه بالعلاقات مع
الخارج بنى علاقات وطيله السنين سواء كان
مع الاتحاد الاوروبي في ملف قضايا
اللاجئين وكمان حماتي هو الان المصيطر على
الحرب بتعت الذهب والموارد في السودان زي
ما نحنا عارفين ان السودان هو الدوله رقم
ثلاثه في انتاج الذهب الافريقي والكثير من
هذا الذهب يتم تهريبه الى الخارج او يدمر
الشيعه موازيه في الدوله السودانيه للجيش
وكذلك بيعزز اتى السياره
تهريب الذهب
اللي هو امين همم
قلبها لما طرحت مثل هكذا فكره حتى وان كان
هناك همم تاريخ للدعمه سريع في تعامله
ولكن ان تصل الى هذه المرحله البعض تذكر
بعض الانتقادات التي طال تدعم السريع منذ
ظهور الى احتجاجات اليوم حتى ان البعض
انتقده لسرقه لقتل الاختصاب طرحت هذه
الانتقادات بشكل متفاوت همم فكيف يمكن ان
يؤثر مثل هكذا تعاقد على الداخل السوداني
وعلى الجيش خاصه
مساء الخير مرحبا استاذ المشاهدين
والضيوفك الكرام
يؤخذ على عده محاور المحور الاول هل تم
هذا التعاقد
باشراف هيئه البريد والاتصالات اذا تم تحت
اشراف هيئه البريد والاتصالات بيقوم مغنا
ومسيطر عليه اذا لم يتم تحت اشراف هيئه
البريد والاتصالات يصبح عمري خارج السيطره
وبالتالي التعامل مع مع مثل هذه الاجهزه
بيكون غير محدود وغير مسيطر عليهم المحور
الثاني هو خطورته على الامن القومي
فقط هذه النقطه لما تتحدث عن هيئه البريد
والاتصالات همم نحن نشير الى اننا نتحدث
عن همم يعني شكل من اشكال التقنيات الجد
عاليات الدقه التي توضع في الهواتف التي
تمكن همم الدعم السريع من التنصت برقيا
وصوتيا على مستخدم هذه الهواتف
فعمليه تنصت تربطها بهيئه البريد
والاتصالات لماذا
يدخل الى السودان لابد ان يمر بهيئه
البريد والاتصالات هذا سيرفر عباره عن
محطه بتاع التنصت على الهواتف وعلى
الاشخاص وتحديد المواقع بيحتاج الى
باندوتش لابد ان يتم التصديق عليها الهيئه
همم اذا لم يتم التصديق بيبقى عمري غير
مسيطر عليه هو عمري خطر الامر الثاني هو
التحديد الامن القومي السوداني همم ليس
استخدامه بواسطه الدعم السريع فقط يمكن
للشركه المورده ان تحصل على كل البيانات
بموجب وضعي كبسه صغير جدا
اللوحه الخاصه بهذه الاجهزه ويمكن ان تصل
المعلومات الى خارج السودان وده الامر
الخطير الثاني الامر السادس همم استخدام
همم هذه الاجهزه هل الدعم السريع محتاج
لهذه التغنيه هل لديه اعداء خارج السودان
او داخل السودان اي جهاز يتم همم
الحصول عليه بيكون هنالك هدف اللي وراءها
الجهاز هذه الامور هي بتمس الامن القومي
السوداني وبالتالي هذه التسريب مهم جدا
واتوقع لانه يتيم فيه اجراءات همم عاجله
جدا لمعرفه همم كيف دخلت واين هي الان ومن
الذي يستخدمها وضمن ده امر طبعا مهم جدا
همم نحدد الجهات اللي بتستخدم ضده هذه
الاجهزه
المكون المدني داخل السودان البعض طرحه
كذلك طرف اخر همم وهو الجيش نعلم بان
الدعم السريع كان في ما قبل يقدم على انه
ميليشيات في اطار الحرف في دار ولكن منذ
2003 عشر تعلم حضرتك بانه اصبح ينظر تحت
قبه الجيش فهذا يطرح سؤالين سؤال الاول
لماذا تخطى وتعد الجيش وتعاقد مع الخارج
والنقطه الثانيه هل يمكن ان تكون عمليات
تنصت لقيادات الجيش خاصه وان البعض يقول
بان البرهان اضعف الجيش وحمل قياداته وهمم
نصبها في الدعم السريع فهل هناك وقوف في
وجه الجيش في هذه المرحله سؤالات يعني
اسئله كثيره تطرح في هذا المشاكل
السلام عليكم
يعني هذه المعلومات ترشيح من الحين لاخر
وان استمعتها الى مثل هذا التقرير قبل
فتره طويله واعتقد ان الصراع السيارات
السوداني والصراع المتواجد في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وصراع الاخطاء
وما يحويه من تاثيرات ومن اثار همم
بعض المؤشرات في اطار تجريم الاخر في اطار
همم يعني البحث عن اشياء عن قضايا قد تكون
تحتاج الى الى معلومات ادقه او تحتاج الى
تفسيرات همم اعمق او تحتاج الى شيء من
الحكمه في اننا نذكر قضيه لديها علاقه
بالامن القومي السوداني او لديه علاقه
بالجيش السوداني وانا استمعت حتى في
التقرير يتحدث عن ان الجيش السوداني ليس
لديه علم طبعا هذا اولا انتقاس من قدر
الجيش السوداني
انتقاش من يعني ال- ال- ال- ال- المسؤوليه
الوطنيه والتاريخيه التي يقوم بها الجيش
السوداني والمؤسسه العسكريه بصوره كامله
المؤثر السودانيه مؤسسه متكامله مؤسسه
صحيح انا اتفق مع الضيفه ان الدعم سريع
همم حصل له تطور لكن حاول تطور حصل في
اطار تطور القوات المسلحه عامه والدعم
السريع وجزء من المنظومه العسكريه
السودانيه واعتقد التطور الذي ترعى للمؤثر
العسكري السودانيه يشمل كل الاجهزه وكل
المؤسسات العسكريه السودانيه اما فيما يخص
الاجهزه
الاليات اول الاشياء المتعلقها كما ذكر
همم ضيفك العزيز ان هذه الاشياء لديها
اجراءات من الدوله التي تصنع وتصدر الى
الدوله التي تستجب او الدوله التي هي يعني
تريد ان تستهلك هذا او هذه الاليات
بالتالي انا اعتقد ان هذا الامر اذا كان
موجود يجب ان لا يصاب في مثل هذا الاتجاه
على الاجهزه السوداني لا وانا لانه هذه
الامور لديها علاقه بالامن القومي
السوداني ولا يمكن ان نتحدث بهم مثل هذه
الحديث
الذي يلتقي احمد فقط صحيح ولكن في هذا
الاطار هل نلوم من نشر من فضح العمليه او
نلوم الجهه التي تخطت هذا المكون الوطني
وتعاقدت مع الخارج
هي مجموعه همم يعني همم تكون هناك صوت لهم
للاخبار التي تنشر دون التاكد وتثبت عنها
وقد يكون هناك صوت لهم ايضا في شكل
التنسيق وما بين المؤسسات حتى لا تخرج مثل
هذه الاخبار التي تضر الامن القومي
السوداني والتمس المؤسسه العسكريه
السودانيه هذه المؤسسه التي يجب ان تظل
متماسك ويجب ان تظل تعمل وفق اجراءات
داخليه تؤسس وتؤطر لنظم همم شكل التطور
فيها وشكل الاستنجاء بالاشياء من الخارج
فيها يكون وفقا للحاجه ولا التقنيه
وللخطط التي تضعها المؤسسه العسكريه كامله
ماذا يحتاج الشرطه وماذا يحتاج الجيش
وماذا يحتاج
وطني احمد خليني اسمع في هذا القطار
الاستاذه رؤى همم حتى وان كان الموضوع
اتجه بنا الى الخلافات او عدم اتوافق كما
يتحدث السودانيون في الفتره الحاليه بين
الجيش وبين ادعم السريع ولكن بصفه عم حتى
وان كان الجيش على علم بهذه الصفقه همم
الى ما سيحتاج او ماذا
يعني ما هي الادوات او ما هي الاهداف التي
سيعمل على همم اثرها الجيش همم باستعمال
هذه الهواتف او اداه التنصت هذا
خلينا نذكر حاجه مهمه انه الان السودان في
وضع فورا فورا ضد اسقاط العسكر نحو اقامه
دوله مدنيه والعدو الان هنا بالنسبه للشعب
السوداني هو العسكر نفسهم وحميته اللي هو
جزء من المنظومه العسكريه رغم انه حميدي
يعتبر
الحركات المسلحه وعملت نوعا ما تقسيم سلطه
اكثر لانها اتفاقيه سلام والدليل الضحايا
كل يوم بيتوفوا وبيموتوا في السودان
الشهداء
تنصب بالتاكيد هتزيد من التنكيل
السلطات الامنيه اتجاه الشعب السوداني دار
الفت نظركم لحاجه مهمه انه حتى حلميه نفسه
في تقارير كثيره بتقول انه هو واسرته زي
ما بيقولوا دوله داخل السودان الدوله دي
بتعتمد على النهد بتاع موارد الذهب من جبل
عامر من 2012 يمكن همم اكثر من 800 شخص
سوداني حدفهم وشرد الالاف والحاجات دي
والصادر مذكوره في صحفيه يعني لو الناس
رجعت من مصادر التقارير الصحفيه ايضا
علاقه حميمه المريبه بروسيا علاقات حميدتي
مع اثيوبيا علاقات حميتي مع
الخارج او تصدر للمشاهد وجوده في نائب
رئيس مجلس السياده هو نائب يعني وظيفه
محدوده جدا رغم ذلك يتقدم في المشهد حتى
مرات البرهان مما يدور على انه حميدتي
مدعوم من الخارج يتم الاعداد حتى يوجد في
المشهد لوقت طويل في مقال في 2019 برده
بتتكلم عن انه حميدتي به انه يكون الوجه
جديد لاداره الدوله السودانيه اللي هو يزو
من القمع جزء من القتل جزء منظومه اصلا من
الاول همم
لازم الناس يتكلم عن الحاجات دي ك الصحفيه
من واجب الصحافه ومن المهنه انه نكشف
التقارير بسيط من الاشياء الدمويه
هذا يبدو تعليقك على الاستاذ احمد الذي
قال يجب ان تنشر هذه المعلومات حتى يتم
تاكد وحتى عندما تاك هناك امن قومي همم
استاذ احمد ان كان لك تعليق على ضيفته
باختصار
من المحللين السياسيين او المراقبين
يتحدثون وفقي يعني مرجعيات او يستنجدون
على معلومات قد تكون المرجعيات في حال
مرجعيات همم يعني ممكن تكون صحيحه او تكون
خاطئه بالتالي انا اعتقد مثل هذه القضايا
الكبيره والتي تمسها الشعب السوداني والتي
تتمس الامن القومي السوداني والذي تمس
المؤسسه العسكريه السودانيه وتمثل الحكومه
السودانيه والتميس مستقبل السودان يجب
التثبت فيها وتثبت من المصادر الحقيقيه
والصحيحه التي تاتي من في هذه المعلومات
حتى لا نشاهم نحن كسودانيين او همم
مراقبين في بعضهم معلومات
تتحدث عن انه يجب ان يكون هناك همم عمليه
تاكيد من السلطات المعنيه بذلك لواء همم
امين همم لماذا همم يعني اقتصر الموضوع
على تسريبات من الجيش
بتصريحات تقول الجيش ليس على عالم بهذه
الصفقه همم لماذا لم يكن الموضوع همم شفاف
همم بالنسبه للداخل السوداني خاصه لان
ضيوفي لا يتفقون في نقطه انه هذا الموضوع
المراد منه اخفاء يعني هناك
نيه اخفاء لهذه الصفقه
من الواضح ان التسريبات الخاصه
بالتطبيع مع اسرائيل او التعامل مع
اسرائيل في المجالات المختلفه كل
المعلومات تاتي من وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه الى الان لم تاتي من وسائل
الاعلام السودانيه وبالتالي هنالك تشقيق
في هذه النوايا لماذا كل فتره بيتم اثاره
قضيه ضد السودان او همم التنوير عن عن
زيارات لوفود اسرائيليه للخرطوم والعكس
اسرائيل ما في تعليق من المصادر السودانيه
الرسميه هذه واحده همم الثانيه ان امر
التطبيع مع اسرائيل في كل المجالات اه هو
همم
يفوت المحطه الاولى وهي الاغا الذي تم
يعني الى الان ما في اي خطوات تمت رسميا
بنسمع عن زيارات بنسمع عن الوفود هنا
وهناك هناك ولكن اسرائيل تحاول تثبيت هذا
الامر وتحاول ايجاد قناه بابعاده السودان
عن محيطه العربي والافريقي على القضايا
القوميه وفي مقدمتها قضيه فلسطين وفي
مقدمتها قضيه الممانعه العربيه لذلك مثل
هذه الاخبار نحن نناقش باعتبار همم لها
خبر موجود
بمركز دراسه الدوليه المحلل السياسي احمد
ومن يكسر رؤى عربي الكاتبه الصحفيه شكرا
جزيلا لكم
ولا نقاش دائما بقيا السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]